[Musique]
la sortie de crise ne pourra intervenir
que dans le cadre d'une vaccination
massive donc tant qu' on n'a pas atteint
au moins la moitié de la population
vaccinée
il faut continuer d'aider l'économie
française à se tenir debout parce que
sinon il ne pourra pas repartir une fois
que le pire de la crise sera passée nous
avons deux trois zones où il faut tout
une impulsion pour faire remonter
l'économie ce n'est pas en mettant les
gens au congélateur comme on l'a fait
puis ensuite en débranchant en disant
débrouillez vous avec une déferlante
il va falloir au contraire orienter les
dépenses tout autrement et dirigé ces
dépenses là si on veut pas avoir une
déferlante est en réalité un ping pong
entre la crise anitea la crise est
connue l'économie française a souffert
au cours des vingt dernières années
d'une désindustrialisation massive ce
constat qui était nier est encore
quelques années est aujourd'hui
largement partagé
il faut également investir dans les
infrastructures physiques numérique et
dans les infrastructures de formation
donc c'est toute une stratégie de
reconstruction d'une offre compétitive
qui doit être mise en oeuvre
mais c'est maintenant ou jamais où il
faut le faire il faut également quand on
regarde le plan de relance de 100
milliards qui est constitué comme on le
sait trois volets il manque un quatrième
volet de renforcement des fonds propres
des entreprises
donc c'est tout une vision d'ensemble et
ce qui est terrifiant c'est que ni les
grands partis de gauche ni les
romantiques droite ni le gouvernement ne
propose deux sorties structurée sur la
base d'une stratégie intégrée
donc on a des initiatives éparses mais
on n'a pas de vision d'ensemble et c'est
très inquiétant
cette question c'est plutôt où on met
l'argent et comment avec quels projets
on on pilote cette utilisation de
l'argent avec la révolution
informationnelle technologiques
profondes l'emploi devient
levier décisif pour transformer notre
production
donc il faut mettre emploi entreprises
et services publics c'est les deux
piliers fondamentaux et les services
publics tout autrement que ce qu'on a
fait bien entendu on a vu une grande
famille on a vu aussi une faillite non
seulement du côté industrie mais même de
ce qui nous reste est par exemple la
recherche chez sanofi a pêché ou pasteur
d 1 sur les brevets non seulement à la
pêcher du lien avec l'industrie de son
recul et de l'obsession de verser des
dividendes tout en licenciant et en
restructurant sans cesse les équipes
si ce qui s'est passé chez sanofi avec
la domination du capital financier mais
aussi de son articulation avec
l'industrie et des projets alors qu'il
va falloir continuer des recherches sur
les vaccins
on n'a pas fini ce qui m'inquiète c'est
que on m'aborde par les choses de
manière extrêmement positive quand on
regarde pourquoi les états unis sont en
avance dans la production des vaccins
c'est qu'ils ont créé des unités
natar pas sur le port militaire et
labarda sur le plan biologique qui
anticipent les révolutions scientifiques
de demain en faisant des appels d'offres
assez massif
lorsqu'il faut agir rapidement il n'y a
rien d'équivalent en france il est
inconcevable que la patrie de pasteurs
ne soit pas dans les premier inventeur
de vaccins effectivement le coc videla
pour des peut-être plusieurs années et
puis il y aura peut-être d'autres
pandémies derrière on peut pas se
ridiculiser à chaque nouvelle crise donc
il faut mettre en oeuvre une politique
est extrêmement dynamique
je suis extrêmement déçu de la de la
pauvreté de la façon la pauvreté
intellectuelle et de la médiocrité de
mise en oeuvre de du gouvernement
général de la france est claire et des
hommes libres s'est réveillé leur
courage
donc il faut voir les choses les yeux
ouverts c'est une citation du grand
maximilien robespierre
cette domination du capital financier il
faut la voir
il faut l'avoir dont elle a besoin
d'argent on a besoin
la chine mais pas de cette domination de
la rentabilité à tout prix
rédactrices on a une révolution
technologique profonde
on a une révolution écologique
démocratique et monétaires enfin c'est
effectivement comme vous le dites on est
dans les conservatismes
on ne s'en sortira pas autrement que en
poussant la coopération ne serait-ce
qu'en faisant en commençant par faire
des vaccins un bien commun de l'humanité
mais ça veut pas seulement dire ça veut
dire des branches et les brevets au
moins pour les 25
mais ça veut dire aussi un appui pour
des capacités de production dans les
différents pays et pour les recherches
dans le monde entier
la france pourrait jouer un rôle
considérable à dessus